What you're about to see is gonna melt your brain
all right here we go can i tell you a secret your
mind is a pendulum swinging between realities
your identities are not something to
be feared but something to be welcomed
this is the best worst day of my life
Welcome back everyone this will be my marvel moon
knight episode 6 finale trailer video there's a
whole bunch of stuff that they have to wrap up a
whole bunch of easter eggs and footage to break
down so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
doctor strange 2 is also coming out next week we
have the moon knight finale and doctor strange
2 coming out in the same week so we're doing a
giveaway for imax tickets for the movie all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions on the video this is mostly
meant to be a moon knight video but obviously some
of what's happening ties in with some of what's
happening in doctor strange multiverse of madness
just because we spent most of episode 5 getting a
couple answers about how some of these alternate
dimensions are connected with the mcu gods it was
going on in doctor strange 2 with them visiting
alternate universes with all the different
variants at the end of episode 5 marc spector and
steven also kind of jake lockley technically were
stuck in the ineos version of the underworld the
one specific to the egyptian gods they call it the
duat the hippo goddess tarouwet explains how
the multiverse connected everything she used
the black panther ancestral plane example you'd
be surprised how many intersectional planes of
untethered consciousness exist like the ancestral
plane oh just gorgeous pretty much when everybody
dies they travel to an alternate dimension which
she called alternate states of consciousness based
on what they believe in so for example black
panther the wakandans when they die they travel
to the ancestral plane because that's part of
their belief system and because of his contract
with the panther goddess boss just like we see
in doctor strange multiverse of madness you can
travel between different dimensions i mean we've
seen it before everybody who's read comics knows
how that works it just so far the way they've
explained it on moon knight in order to bring
someone back from an alternate dimension into the
mcu in their physical form you actually have to
have their bodies so for example odin doesn't have
a body anymore in the mcu so he can't really come
back in that same way iron man's body was cremated
so they can't bring mcu iron man back in that way
either the way that marc specter the way that
steven grant and technically jake lockley too
exist right now is that they've been separated
from their physical body so that's kind of like
the ancestral plane where you basically separate
different aspects of existence from each other
as for the jake lockley of it all i do believe
that we did see a version of jake lockley just
briefly because of the brooklyn accent or new york
accent however you want to think about it there
was a brief scene at the beginning of episode 5
where he's talking about how he's fine and they
dose him with that sedative it sounds like during
that moment he briefly slipped into a completely
different new york accent and that was probably a
version of jake lockley you're really good i tell
you what i feel like a million dollars never
felt so good i'm gonna set myself up thank you
there been several scenes in previous episodes
hinting at him just kind of referencing the
character like the third sarcophagus all the
taxicabs in the different episodes and both
steven and marc arguing with each other about how
they did not wind up killing that group of thugs
in the earlier episode it wasn't me it wasn't
me that means it was probably jake lockley that
stabbed all those people he's the stabby one
turns out they haven't completely explained
when jake lockley came into existence and what
the inspiration for his character was like we
learned why steven grant was created he was based
on one of the characters from their favorite movie
but where did the inspiration for jake lockley
come from because he's sort of like the travis
bickle aspect of their personality like
the really crazy really violent personality
it's just not clear if he was also there when they
were a child like he also expressed him as a child
or if it happened later in life when he broke
around his mother's death we'll probably learn
a little bit more about that during the finale
it just seems like a big hanging plot thread
that they would want to explain before the end
of the series even though there's still a lot of
hanging plot threads to resolve as we also saw at
the end of episode five you see all those purple
souls just arcing down into the duad it means
that ah mit has been released somehow arthur
harrow has found a way to release her and she just
started judging people and mass doing her version
of infinity gauntlet snaps the reason why you're
not seeing crazy amounts of people here like why
the sky isn't just totally purple with a ton of
people because she's kind of insta-judging people
is because the only people that are winding up
in this place that she's judging are the ones who
actually believe in the egyptian gods and ammit
herself so she can judge anybody she wants but
when she kills someone the only people that wind
up in this version the afterlife are the ones who
believe the same things that they believe so if
she walked up and judged a bunch of asgardians
they would wind up in a version of hell because
that's their alternate dimension that represents
the underworld for them hell spelled h-e-l with
one l so right now when you see all that purple
energy arcing out of the top of the great pyramid
it's coming from that same room that we saw in
the previous episode where they had the meeting of
the gods because of the size of her following most
of the people that she's in the middle of judging
right now are just kind of localized to this area
around egypt but eventually the more people see it
the more people believe in her the more powerful
she becomes because a lot of god's power is
relative to the size of their following so
eventually the effect would grow and grow and grow
to cover the entire planet and then eventually the
entire galaxy then eventually the entire universe
so for instance right now she's not as powerful
as the infinity stones per se but she could become
that powerful theoretically if enough time went by
and enough people believed in her there's a bunch
of footage of moon knight and arthur harrow both
flying at each other with moon knight wearing his
full costume and then both having full powers like
you would expect the version of infinity war with
them all using their powers fighting each other
in a traditional superhero movie that means that
towerette was probably successful in contacting
leyla somehow to be the one to actually free
khonshu so that somehow khonshu was able to help
marc spector and steven rescue themselves make it
back to the world of the living into their body
and then also when he came back because conscious
released from his prison they have their powers
again so that the healing factor will take care
of the bullet wounds that are still in their
body because if you brought them back right now
they would just instantly die again because the
bullet wounds that's the reason they have to
release khonshu before marc spector can come
back to life yes of course i totally think that
steven grant will come back again eventually
they're trying to do as much of the comics as
they can and the whole idea in the comics is
they kind of did this run where they were in
the hospital but it was a way for him to sort
of work his mental state out and all the different
personalities came to an agreement with each other
everyone inside his head realized that they needed
each other to be a better superhero to survive
better it's like when steven grant and marc
spector hug each other like they're happy to
see each other whereas before they were kind of at
war with each other the same thing will eventually
be true for jake lockley as well it's just that
they're not totally aware of what's going on with
him yet like all three of them will eventually
meet each other and then it'll really get crazy
i know a lot of you are asking why the other gods
is part of the enid allowing this to happen why
are they ignoring what kancho is telling them well
one they kind of hate consu to begin with so they
don't want to believe him in most gods are pretty
capricious and pretty lazy the other gods probably
could have found out what was really going on if
they really wanted to but that would have required
them to expend some effort everyone posting their
gore was right memes just wait for that everybody
posted that thanos was right memes after avengers
infinity war and avengers end game came out
it'll be the same thing for christian bales
gore the god butcher after thor love and thunder
so what'll probably happen during the course
of the finale like when things really get crazy
and they'll start fighting each other is you'll
have moon knight trying to stop arthur harrow and
you'll have some of the other gods like khonshu
trying to stop ammit like person versus person and
gods vs gods the reason why most of them ignore
what the other gods are doing too is to avoid an
all-out god-tier level avengers end game situation
because that would basically lead to the end of
all reality which is kind of what we're threatened
with during doctor strange multiverse of madness
that's why i think they're waiting to like the
very end of the finale episode to sort of tease
what's happening with werewolf by night in the
next places where moon knight is going to cross
over in the mcu because they've been building
moon knight as a sort of self-contained mini
series like it's not supposed to get a season two
but moon knight himself is supposed to be a big
deal in the future marvel phase four marvel phase
five it's kind of like what they're doing with the
wandavision series like there's only one series
of wandavision they're not gonna do wandavision
season two because right after that she goes into
doctor strange multiverse of madness scarlet witch
will continue to be a really big character
going forward in the mcu in marvel phase 5.
same basic deal with all these midnight suns
characters like blade black knight werewolf by
night any other characters like ghost rider the
punisher that they eventually introduced in the
mcu the whole thing with the moonite origin is
that they retroactively sort of worked in his
backstory he actually started out in the werewolf
by night comics but he was already a fully formed
character in the slightly different version so
later on when they gave him an actual backstory
they reckoned a couple things there'll probably
be some references to that during the werewolf
by night special that they have this halloween
mahershala ali's blade character is supposed to
come back during that and i think they're supposed
to tease what's happening with the blade movie
which is happening next year as well i think
that's when we're meant to see black knight kit
harington come back with the ebony blade the full
armor have a big midnight sunstyle crossover and
it'll be some other big villain that they all team
up to face during that blade movie if you spotted
any other easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments my full moon knight finale video
will post next wednesday after they release it in
my non-spoilery doctor strange 2 review we'll post
tuesday morning so make sure you enable alerts for
that so you don't miss that some of you also been
asking me about doing merch for my channel or how
to support the channel now youtube is actually
letting you support me by leaving tips on my
videos using that special heart underneath each of
the actual videos it's right here they're supposed
to give you guys some special power-ups whenever
you do that for each of my videos so when you try
that out let me know if it's working for you so
if you want to support the channel that's the
best way to do it right now thank you to all of
you for all of your support congratulations dylan
randall you're the giveaway winner for my last big
marvel video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details and
everyone click here for my new doctor strange 2
x-men professor x trailer video and click here for
my full moon knight episode 5 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!